it's never been something I've really
cared for and I love watching all day
long
well Shay first of all I just want to
ask how you're doing right now there's a
lot going on in the world and and what
is life like for you right now like a
mental check yeah you know I think every
day it's different and for us we're
really just taking it one day at a time
we don't know what tomorrow is going to
be like but um you know we're looking on
the positive side and being able to have
this time for Atlas I'm sure that you
never thought that the majority of your
first year of motherhood would be spent
like this I mean what has the experience
been like for you have there been
challenges has it been more fun because
you are with with her constantly yeah
it's been a little bit of both you know
I mean every single day with her has
been so wonderful considering that you
know that wouldn't have been the case
before Matt and I both travel so often
that you know being able to spend this
much time as a family together at with
her at such an early age is incredible
however there are obviously challenges
because I wish my mom and my dad could
be here Matt's family you know my
grandma obviously I want to have time
with Atlin so as soon as you know things
hopefully open up and it's safe I can't
wait to go to Vancouver and bring her
over there so yeah absolutely
how is your relationship with Matt going
during quarantine you know it's been
funny because we both obviously are on a
lot of zoom calls ourselves so I'm like
okay today you got living room I got
kitchen we'll switch it about one
o'clock I'll feed her you got the
nighttime shift like it has been funny
because we've just been switching off
literally like you know team up players
you know so it's been funny um and like
I said I'm grateful to have this time
it's a family right now it's actually
been great so you know there's there's
great days and there's not-so-great days
but um we need them all to appreciate
the other ones when you think about your
relationship with Matt and I mean you
said things are good and you guys have
really figured things out do you ever
see yourself wanting to get engaged is
that you know ya know
ever been something I've really cared
for and I love I'll watch the old days
on I love attending I love being a part
of my friends anybody's to be quite
honest it's just not something I care
for myself and I you know it's something
that Matt and I have spoken about it
he's kind of in like you sure and like
yeah like I work so well right now and
it's great and this dynamic just works
for us I may not always be the correct
way but it works and that's sort of how
I have to go you know yeah yeah what is
your your favorite thing about seeing
him as a dad yeah so much fun to watch
it's so much fun and you know the best
part is truly just seeing how wrapped
around her finger he's already is I mean
how does have these little hands but let
me tell you if he is all around them
because she I mean he can't say no
already and I'm like I told you so you
know that's that's a relationship and
it's so nice to see it grow
is she talking yet is she saying words
at all so she's not talking yet but her
word right now is Wow
and I honestly nursing but I don't know
if that came from that tik-tok downs
like wow you can really wow you can
really die
so yeah I hear might not have heard that
quite often but every time she's like
wow and it's just the funniest thing
because I can be doing anything and I
get a WoW from her so obviously she said
Brett do you know kind of her her first
word
[Music]